每次我做這個非常勇敢隨意的群大
就很多姐妹追求我教程
今天跟我就是來教作驗了
其實對著她這個非常簡單
你們肯定能學的會
而且我覺得她說那種是一卷是一妹的
一妹可以美好幾天
她第一天剛學圈
熟悦內相對種談一國小姐
人的那種隨意大模啦
到第二天的時候
她那個卷會變得會被小一點
就變成那種法師用感風
所以她如果說現在馬上開始
一步先給頭按到某個一點點的快樂
用量不用太多
這樣可以讓我們的頭髮都會有公子
我再稍微就好
而且它可以請教一些隔樂的作用
這樣捲出來之後頭髮都會顯得毛髮
還會覺得你怕質疑嗎
現在來給頭髮分層
我們可以分為這樣中下三層
上面這一層
一定一定要戴堵流出來捲
因為她決定了
我們的努力很高高
這個卷發棒的溫度非常重要
溫般就設置在
155到160這樣
因為卷發棒很久溫度
太高他卷出來
就會很死亡很生意
就顯得推老
然後我測試下來150到160
這個溫度是恰到好處的
他卷出來不會有名證的
這個很浮度是那種微卷的
很有色眉感
而且行手在這個溫度
卷的話也沒有那麼容易翻出
頭髮剝到兩邊
非常出意消作的頭髮
然後你要注意
是不管我們卷內一邊的頭髮
這個卷發棒的是假片
它一定是超期間
大概流量三隻寬的編亡外選
編卷
這兩天中
我們要定期兩週時間短
這個卷度就會很難保持
時間長了
它就會整合很特別明顯
非常顯負
編流七秒之後
把他卷發棒繞出來
往下拉
感覺都是停留七秒鐘
這樣一個卷度就OK
現在我們卷好了
不管他卷內一邊的
就是重複剛才的操作
現在我已經把第一層都換卷好了
用一個相比的
前五、五、第二層
OK
我把最上面的這一層
再再來一個小酒
這裡也是分成兩邊
抖法跟剛才是一模一樣的
這樣變得多多卷完了
它們就是輸在一起
然後到我們流海和鼓勵的地方
我們流海呢
手法跟上面也是一樣的
就應該是我們流海
只需要選三四樓中
就可以了
就要對更加的水液
邊了走的話
這件就還是7秒
就流海的地方是三四樓
現在就完了
然後只要過一波
把橘橘橘橘橘橘橘橘橘橘
一邊是被成解起來的高度頂著吃
鼓勵的話
然後緣就放縫縫微
這個可以重縫兩到三次
它的古風就出來了
大概放到另一邊取架下的頭髮
還是同樣的頭髮
另一邊也一樣
每邊第二個兩三層的小酒出來
差不多現在在模一樣的地方
就會感覺
更有個庫縫
然后现在我已经卷完了
这是非常非常的拥抱的这些很随意
一点都会老戏
然后你们感快来试试
按上次国际的时候就可以有个美变的卷
它是完了